[Music]
I am honored to introduce to you the
creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean casca High bottom
I have summoned you all here for the
10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district
to fight to the death in The Hunger
Games from District 12 Lucy gray bear
[Music]
there has been a change this year as a
mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles not
survivors
mentor
so best to take care of you
carry me in that Arena
you start by thinking I can actually win
I'm lucky flickerman first ever host of
The Hunger Games enjoy the show
[Music]
three two
what happens in there
filled with the terror becoming prey
see how quickly we become predator
see how quickly civilization disappears
[Music]
there's a natural goodness built into us
all
across that line into evil
or not
you hear that boy
it's the sound of snow
falling
[Music]
how wonderful that we all get to be here
for someone's final performance it's
my everything is about winning
the monsters all of you
it's the things we love most
destroy us
[Music]
[Applause]
I am finding being alive fascinating
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
it's breathtaking
when you see sand here imagine water if
you dive in you can't reach the bottom
you dive in yes it's cold swimming I
don't I don't believe you
in the shadows of arracus lie many
Secrets
but the darkest of them all may remain
foreign
[Music]
treaties were still alive
have you ever had a dream about your
first ride
don't try to impress anyone
you're brave we all know that
be simple be direct
nothing fancy I understand
[Music]
we gave them something to hope for
thy knife ship then shatter
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Jonas
we need your help
we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
men whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
this is a bad idea just a little bit
[Music]
Jonas
we've got company
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
that's the apex predator
everybody might get to the station
three massive eggs and who knows what
else have escaped the breach
it just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
I wanna know
[Applause]
you've never seen this before they
hunted it back
all right
we can relax this place is Meg proof I
mean Jonas was always afraid of this but
I was also thinking
[Music]
it's a peaceful place in the sky
are you going to heaven
no
why not
you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven
[Music]
intelligence created
impregnated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
for as long as AI is a threat
we will never stop hunting mountains
this is a fight for our very existence
whatever's in there they're sure worried
about someone getting in
yeah we're getting out
[Music]
we're just saying we can't go to heaven
because you're not good
[Music]
and I'm not a person
yeah it's a key
belts
[Music]
we are this close to winning the war
execute her or we go extinct
[Music]
they're coming to get me
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
the darkness has found us again prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming
[Music]
back up Oh I thought we were boys
you want it
not a human here I'm nobody I ain't even
seen nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
ever faced anything like this
let them come
[Music]
yo Noah Take the Wheel
I had a vision
people burning
everything destroyed it was Athena she
was doing it
I was doing it we won't let that happen
I saw what you did in the ring
I knew it had to be you say it
what if I told you Sienna here is The
Reincarnation of the goddess Athena
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
how does it feel to be a goddess
sometimes I feel like I'm a guest in my
own body
are you ready to start your training the
Pegasus night is brave
humble and committed to protecting
Athena with his life
how the hell did you do that
or that Oasis is unlike any other before
[Music]
you think I wanted any of this
powers of liability
since he learns to control it no living
man will be able to stop
you might want to buckle up
thought you were the only night in town
foreign
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
met a girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
she came back a total dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
oh
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
we're always searching for a family and
how we found each other
are you ready for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
and beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
you've never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
[Music]
I lost my parents
that pain
[Music]
made me who I am
it's been a lifetime trying to right the
wrongs of the path
as if fighting crime would bring my
parents back
you actually did it
I can't imagine what you've been through
I love you monkey you lost both parents
in one day
I went back in time to save my parents
instead
I completely broke the universe
and if you went back and changed the
past this world must die
you change the future
do you know what this symbol stands for
means hope right
I will help you if I thought
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
foreign
[Applause]
no matter what we do
We're not gonna be able to fix this no
no we die
[Music]
thank you
you're strapped to your parachutes it
wasn't yours
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great oh yeah yours must be here
all right whatever whatever wow whatever
so are you like a cow or a Dalmatian I
am the spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish what oh okay
he's lying to you and I think you know
it
what's up danger
miles wanna get out of here oh when so
wait a minute there's an elite crew with
all the best spider people in it who's
the new guy danger this is unbelievable
this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea what's the guy got to do to join
this Fighter Team you can never be part
of this don't even get me started on
Doctor Strange and a little nerd back on
Earth 1999.99
he had a terrible
you have a baby
I'll take it from here
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
send me home I can't do that I can do
both
Spider-man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
you can't run forever dude I can't lose
one more friend
no idea what are you doing everyone
keeps telling me how my story is
supposed to go nah
I'm gonna do my own thing
[Music]
stop Spiderman
and then I looked at my uncle and ah let
me guess he died
oh
[Music]
death Island
Captain Rambo
what the hell are you doing
entering the jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury
hello hello
[Applause]
[Music]
is this an Avengers test
where's Captain Rambo
[Music]
what the hell now
hi we're looking for Kamala Khan
[Applause]
okay so our powers are entangled I can
manipulate light energy and you I could
totally show you
hi where's our daughter Wherever You Are
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
this is Commander Mills my ship was hit
by an undocumented asteroid
[Music]
transporting 35 passengers
on a long-range exploratory mission
[Music]
send help
with crash landed on an Uncharted
Celestial body
[Music]
I don't know where we are
I've located One Survivor
a giant
the atmosphere is breathable
there's something alien out there
all right
you need to be quiet and move
you and I are gonna get home oh family
ready
[Applause]
[Music]